mass cremations and burials have become
the norm in a country
where the bodies of coronavirus victims
are piling up
crematoriums and burial grounds are
working day and night
and even burning bodies in parks and car
parks
families of the dead mourn for their
loved ones who succumbed not just to the
virus
but to the shortages of beds and oxygen
the country i'm feeling very bad i have
money i have everything but i can't save
my sister
because no bed nothing nothing like that
no gas
no oxygen no bed where we can do where
we can go
international aid has started arriving
but family members of the sick are still
lining up to find oxygen
wherever they can they say the
government should have been better
prepared
if this would happen like last year then
it would have been okay nobody knew
about it
but they got a year and they wasted it
completely on election rallies and all
the other stuff
so it's heartbreaking but we don't have
any other options
the world health organization said
nowhere is the situation worse
than in india india is really
heartbreaking as the director general
has said in the in the
the exponential growth that we've seen
in case numbers is really
truly astonishing we have seen similar
trajectories of
increases in transmission in a number of
countries it has not been at the same
scale and it has not had the same
level of impact and burden on the health
care system that we've seen in india
the world health organization also said
mass gatherings contributed to india's
surgeon cases
but despite the rapid spread of the
virus hindu pilgrims gathered again in
the northern town of hadidwa
for the kummela festival the government
has been criticized for allowing
large religious and political gatherings
to go ahead
and both the central and delhi
governments have been accused of
insensitivity to people's suffering
and blatant inequality and setting their
priorities
as people continue to die because of a
lack of hospital beds and oxygen
delhi's government is planning to
convert a hundred rooms in this
five-star hotel
to set up a covert 19 health facility
for staff at the delhi high court
and their families a controversial move
it was forced to scrap
following criticism from the public and
the high court itself
elizabeth peranam al jazeera new delhi
well dr simet ray is head of critical
care at hawley family hospital in new
delhi he says the health care system
in the indian capital has been
completely overwhelmed
this whole situation seems totally
devastating
beds are full icu beds are full
ventilator all ventilators are occupied
there are no beds on the uh in the wards
our emergency room is full of patience
they have nowhere to go
you know even if we don't have beds in
the icu or on the wards we
if we want to send them somewhere else
there is no organized way of sending
them away
and all these patients are who are who
are there in the er are
all those who need high amounts of
oxygen or actually would need a
ventilator bed or an icu bed
uh if they could get one so so that is
the situation we are losing patients we
could we could save
because there is uh you know no acts i
mean
the numbers are overwhelmed there are
patients landing up in our emergency
room
brought dead because they have been
running from hospital to hospital
in an ambulance or in their cars with
oxygen cylinders trying to get a bed and
they either run out
of the oxygen or or the oxygen was not
enough for them and
or their cases were so severe so it's a
devastating situation absolutely in that
sense our
young resident doctors our nurses etc
are totally traumatized by their
fighting heart they're
doing as much as they can they can they
are doing way more than they can
actually they are
working really hard but they are
devastated emotionally because of what
they see that they cannot save a lot of
patients
because we are running out of resources
in terms of beds and ventilators
and icu beds particularly